Reactions were mixed after Felix Tshisekedi
was announced the winner.
From jubilation
to consternation, people certainly made their
feelings known.
The opposition leader wasn't expected to win
the Presidential vote in the Democratic Republic
of Congo.
But he edged out his main rival, putting the
country on course for its first democratic
transfer of power in almost 60 years since
independence.
I know many of you find it hard to accept
- but I say it with sincerity, I pay homage
to President Joseph Kabila, President of the
Republic...
Today, we must no longer consider each other
as adversaries but rather as partners in democratic
change in our country.
Some believe Tshisekedi won by cutting a deal
with President Joseph Kabila, who's clung
to power for 18 years.
Although Kabila's preferred candidate only
came third, the man expected to win, Martin
Fayulu, is among many contesting
the results.
These results do not reflect the truth of
the ballots.
This is obviously an unacceptable electoral
fraud of a nature that will provoke general
chaos across the country.
Meanwhile, the country's influential Catholic
church is already questioning the vote.
It says official results do not match the
outcome compiled by its 40,000 observers at
all polling stations across the troubled country.
The church has also called for calm.
Still, many people are upset.
In Goma, many did not hide their feelings
amid the potential for unrest.
We don't want this Machiavellian sale of the
Congolese people's power.
We are going to call on Article 64 of our
Constitution.
In the end, though, experts say it will be
up to the country's constitutional
court
to rule
on
the vote.